with glowing Hearts we see the rise the true
north strong and free Oh Canada We Stand arise
we stand on God for the here's Evander Kane to
the panther line where HEI lost his stick it went
flying where hegi kicks it ahead to mikola
and then buar fell down eiko Mika moves in
centers r get score and we're tied again well
this is just a series of bad luck here at the
neutral zone and Aon s goes flying in the air for
higgy boomberg ends up tripping over it and then
Mika tries to get that puck across the crease it
doesn't quite make it I think you're right gu he
gets credited with his second goal of the game
and the oers have to be shaking their heads of
bad luck that they justed P Insight kachuck how
did that stay out a caping chage for the Captain
off a pretty set up from Norris and he'll be
looking back wondering what happened on that
one back in for gon's be P for passing score oh
with the he broke the camera he's got glass in
the neet that's the problem ah here you go this
what it looked like if someone shot a puck at
your TV or a window you were standing in front
of open at the right point is gutus he'll Wind
and Fire off of San Jose stick score it floated
in the air and Blackwood never picked it up and
it floated in the net it's an alleyoop goal for
Radco goodas there there it's way up in here you
see Blackwood he has no idea it was Mike Hoffman
that came out to try and block the shot and my
goodness when things are not going well like they
have not been going well those are the types of
things that seem to happen more often against St
so he's match that total up to seven points Weir
car oh what a stop unbelievable as dvor Rob by
aeden Hill Christian dorak trying to figure out
how that puck did not go in the net unreal from
aeden Hill to recover get that first regulation
loss and oh what a save by Demco he atones for his
own error he got caught behind the net fired on
goal by Paul Mary and Demco came scrambling back
to make a marvelous save and keep this game tied
Monday prior to that Tuesday game Shepard gets a
signals cross there has to Scurry back in the cage
and it's a slam dunk the Islanders have tied it
everything's about communication shot that puck
to early hit the skate of the defender one off
the Stick of power and high and off the glass
long shot they score elers with the shot what
a weird play as he's holding the offensive line
and he just whips it to the net eers was going to
change at the end of a shift he'll take that one
all day long as he's all smiles you've been around
for 20 years you know how to act on the ice and on
the bench mark pay attention because here comes a
buck and he bails out his trainer that might have
caught gentleman in the back of the head make
the save make a fan happy and Steve kazari I
believe no it's going to be rank letting us know
what the call is as Garrett ranks Tangled Up with
the equipment except there's a malfunction with
the equipment the review there was goal tender
interference yeah no goal R you're one for one K's
career is it in is it not does it count they have
yet to see a goal shoots fir wide up the to go s
drops it back and comes SP going to pass AC the
Stars he bats it in titim STS up an incredible
hand play R it for Ottawa oh what a goal what
a tough way to lose a game if rer didn't move his
head it would have hit it weaves his way and finds
Carlson in front rust the rer at save B back St
Brian Russ the hero and it's not a California
Dream the penguins have swept their way through
the West Coast for the second time in franchise
history 43 over La we got a little review here
possibly after a video review it was determined
that the play was offside therefore the call of
the ice is overturned there's no goal please the
call for 137 oh boy well it's one thing when it's
an empty net goal taken away by being offside in
Anaheim this one has a little extra sting nice
drop pass rust will try again comes behind the
net W around score are you kidding me take that
one to the bank Brian rust Twitches a California
sweep and the Penguins top the Kings 43 and OT
you got to be kidding me and this is what I got
from being in Atlanta It's My Bobblehead so they
they hand these things out in November or December
that night not very long after 9/11 security
was at a you know was at a high so there was a
package on the MARTA the transit system they shut
down the MARTA they had to investigate they found
my bobblehead in a box Andrew brunette said the
next day they should have found out that earlier
because the box was probably talking J first
the load in F shoots PR makes a stop rebound
score the puck was tipped in front of the shot
by bson Brady kachuck parked there and ottawa's
got the opening goal I think Brady kachuck gets
a piece of that completely by accident Drake Bon
dancing in the pile lost the edge speeds it
back and Chuck scores what a feed by stla and
kachuck got his second Barry right down Broadway
shot R goas ties the game and two look at that
celebration there by the beard the butcher as he's
known to his teammates rat goas drops off Hughes
in front tipped in M you think it's an own goal
Hughes will get credit the beat goes on for the
canu captain who ties the game in one there's
hin shot and scored on the rebound pass it box
a short-handed shot score sends it low triangle
passing score shot save made rebound another save
score flurry seated down Puck Lo scored he get in
Robertson one timer score five Power Play Goals
in the game Li Johnston shorthanded he scores
the Stars put a snowman up here in St Paul it
is 8 to3 five Power Play Goals and two shorties
unbelievable P checked Away by dery Evangelista
not aware and now out of the box comes steter
steter in he scores a stunning play Troy steter
picks up a loose puck right out of the Penalty
Box and ties the hockey game turnover and just
clearing the puck little bit of awareness there
talk you got to be ready to go you have to know
that penalty's expiring to forsling there's the
shot knocked down in front Reinhardt the te they
score he banked it in when you're hot you're hot
and you can score goals from behind the goal line
he realized that Soder Bloom was out of position
he had his legs spread off balance why not just
deflected in off the goal tender that's exact
that's a set play and then twisted around by
a follow look out Bon back to the goal they score
and Kyle Conor with Bennington n of the net makes
it 41 another little miscue behind the net here
between the blues goenda row dppi sends one across
and forsberg stopped that it pops back out of his
glove for what an early spectacular save he gloves
it and puts it down like he's just going to roll
it to the corner this is on the line rips it out
of the air I think they're taking a little Peak
at this just to see if this goes over the line at
1945 video doesn't lie it ends up going just
over you see the frustration of Anton forsburg
and like I said before you make a save like that
times you want the B for the doubt but it just
made it over Mar bus It Forward Charlie Cole
Tock to Cole who has a hatrick for the first
time in his NHL career Sun selfish p and like
they wanted Co to get the hatrick to get one
that gives a little room for nean to drop
Taris shoots off the post rebound jordano
can't jam it in oh he had it right in his feet
along the goal line and somehow couldn't knock
it in the goal J I don't know H the back
of his SK right there I don't know how he
didn't put that into the net he actually made
a save on himself he did he kicked it out up
no thanks Joey a timer over the head of lukin IT a
rebound is put in and Denny bin with some absolute
sorcery from the corner are you kidding me nobody
expected that Lucan in absolutely surprised he's
going are you serious Sega Genesis play almost
just held down the shoot button you think you have
travel problems this is Victor Hond chasing down
his own luggage on the tarmac right they're people
just like you I mean that happens to you all the
time Ray he's got to have a good bag though the
wheels are good it picked up some momentum maybe
he's asking Cory Perry for some help the old
teammates Quinn Hughes JT Miller shoots at both
posts hit one post maybe hit the bar and then the
other post P's calling goal the referee waved It
Off and there you go it did go in I guess it hit
the near side post hit the back bar then the far
side post I guess and JT Miller's made it 5 to2 on
the power play all right let's break this down you
got to keep your eye on the puck but what do you
do when it's the stick coming your way you watch
out pegar good job picking up your head at the
last minute you didn't knock over your notes and
then you calmly hand the stick back to little scen
nicely done you know I've had a lot of things
happen between the benches and a lot of close
call Hood punks I've never had a I stick off that
high like that before to the side patteron besser
[Music] scores he's coming back soon oh TI in
front it's in as it's a first career goal for
Kevin Kinski off of yeah off of radish skate
blade that that was the key there go despair
back to ma shoot bouncy Puck score I think it's
a run r for David Pon I think this hits the hip
of Pon yeah that didn't catch a stick wild
carum might AE up get it down nobody knows
where it is as is Fourth of the Year side of
the net Theo out in front for KBS and oh my
goodness ATI Mercy he just robbed Payton kreb's
blind oh ding didn't have his equipment on they
dropped the puck he had his stick and his mask
on the top of the net and they dropped the puck
oh man give the guy a break glove wasn't on
he he's yelling at and he's got to quickly
get everything back on I would like to know
what was the linesman explaining to the two
captains while we were away it went on for a long
time it looked like a UFC weighin Ben staring at
Marian and then at the end the stripes cleared
out and the two the two of them stared at one
another had a quick word and then away they went
to their respective benches antha for the slot it
changed directions and it's in Anthony man's
going to get credit for this goal on a funky
bounce in front of the net a sheepish look as
he went to the bench knowing that that was an
intended pass but it Banks off the body Phil de
justy back to Meers long shot got behind Miller
to the line kept out by Morgan the spotlight came
on people upstairs thought it was in and oh might
be in that's in Morgan was there with the backand
the referee initially waved it off but the crowd
knows what's going on after reviewing the
play the puck completely crossed the goal
line back across cbar calling for it CLS in Fe
it back across they score go bar get it as it
baks in well I mean BR rales had some crazy cars
this one I think goes in off a defenseman's stick
and just a friendly bounce for gosis Bear to even
the score R again up with with it is tamarus and
dander with up go down tucks it in he has done
it for a 50 streak game down was Demco and then
right off of the knee of Meyers as he's trying
to help his goenda off the post almost tried to
reach himself back and KNE Lander slid it to the
area off the knee and in and just like that it's
a two- two game Newton Hopkins up to Dereck Ryan
short handed scores that one just trickled right
through the wickets on Johanson really good
hard work by Ryan and that that's a miscue by
Johansson that went in like a curling Rock sliding
to the button there and I think Johansson was just
anticipating a move that never happened and he
opened the five hole and a went in yeah that's
a good stop by lingren he had to face it two on
one the first on look at this from TJ ooshi did
you see that yes I did the lift he lifted it
and he held it on the stick for a good count
of 1 10002 and he did it twice dude has ridiculous
hands oh he always has and to do that in a highpe
game get out of here four minutes with which
to work in the second strong great passin score
three unanswered for the cats missplay by ransky
triying to go up the wall Four Guys caught three
behind the goal line it's four on four you got
to have man on man you have to have someone in
front they don't have anybody strong steals
back to Ras oh what a stop Loos in the blue
as it covered up by Toronto oh my god did a leaf
get a hand on that let's see it looked like that
was close you can't close your hand on the puck
in the crease boy that was close the Toronto
player covers the Pu well he did put his hand
on the puck by that Replay for for a second so
in a goal this game first career penalty shot
for sprong and it's a goal Daniel sprong wow J
comes to H and shoots it's off the ti ham counts
off the back of the neet they're going to penalty
shot penalty shots going to be called second
straight game of a penalty shot for handling
the puck in the crease Eric branstrom closed his
handle the puck has been awarded a penalty shot
for an Ottawa player closing his hand on the puck
in the crease and he absolutely handles it and
throws it he saw Daniel sprong scored penalty shot
goal last night against Toronto right the first
ever penalty shot goal scored in a game outside
North America and here comes the next Jo hon stop
by forsberg Gallagher's lost his left scate lane
and Pearson is trying to help them to the bench
it's like Bambi so adventures in skate blades
the movie tonight at the Bell Center featuring
these two guys so there goes Suzuki as you can
see it slide off now he's got the puck Gallagher
gets crushes he's got a long way to go across
and it's what's your style going to be what's
your system going to be to get across there that's
a long way to the bench do you practice that in
the offseason slide crawl it should start pring
it Duane Springs it Sean has a step Sean score
oh he is him more moves than a snake falling
out of a tree and then tosses a back end over
top in front of eigor sterkin at the moment
huge retrieves it he shoots his third shot
already here and it trickles in but the whistle
had blown the pck get entered on the original
shot on a continuous play therefore we have a
goal on the ice so it is a goal even with the
Whistle the puck had entered off the original
shot that's the decision from Toronto that was
the original call on the ice the red line he
flips it in up was waiting for it he was on
of the net it's in the that another fortuitous
bounce this time for NES nikov he comes out of
the net here but this Puck doesn't have the speed
to get by the trapezoid and when that happens he
gets caught in no man's land PKA tries to work
around traffic he's knocked to the ice no arms
going up at this point and front scores Alex
tuck he's going to play this this Puck to the
front of the net and as Carolina tries coming down
layers there and a little Sloop underneath Alex
taka will poke that one away in the same motion
as he pokes it away bang a puck hits the ground
and he takes the shot old habits die hard for
Austin it's wrong Penalty Box sorry about that
guys's got to move over that's a that's a good
one he has a laugh creatures of habit that's
what we are Vancouver's got everything going for
here's a giveaway front scores Sher from St well
this is one where just the quick reaction wasn't
there from Joseph wall I don't think he felt the
pressure at all behind him Kyu farsight Thomas
Shan CHS he scores the hatrick his fourth career
hatrick what a shot by Shan and another Power
Play goal for the hatrick which D it in and he
scores the ha trick for B davit two hat tricks
tonight and the hats are flying in Denver you
don't get one you get two hat tricks tonight
for the price of one to low besser below the
goal line and Allen sticks behind him Jake
Allen no ST it's well behind him MF bre some
space shoots score Canucks take advantage Ilia MF
beats Allen with no stick helpless feeling Allen
thought about going to try and get it knew that
it was a little bit too far away and it [Music]
cost
what